[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
derrick shovin found guilty of all three
charges in the death of george floyd
bail is revoked bond is discharged and
the defendant is remanded to the custody
of the hennepin county sheriff
how the final words from the attorneys
could have
impacted the jury's decision human
beings
make decisions in highly stressful
situations
that they believe to be right the reason
george floyd
is dead is because mr sheldon's heart
was too small
plus the defense's motion for mistrial
after a representative calls for
protesters to be confrontational
if there's not a guilty verdict i wish
elected officials would stop
talking about this case and why derek
chovin wants the judge
not the jury to decide if he should
receive a sentence
higher than state guidelines i'm willing
to waive it and have judge kiel decide
on those issues
law and crime daily covering court cases
from
coast to coast
welcome to law and prime daily i'm
angelica spanos in our studios brian
buckmeyer is in minneapolis covering the
derrick chauvin trial
and with us as always is terry austin
while the jury has reached a verdict for
the former officer
charged in the death of george floyd
let's get right to it
we the jury in the above entitled matter
has to count one
unintentional second degree murder while
committing a felony find the defendant
guilty
same caption verdict count two we the
during the above entitled matter has to
count two
third degree murder perpetrating an
eminently dangerous act find the
defendant guilty
same caption verdict count three we the
jury in the above entitled matter has to
count three
second degree manslaughter culpable
negligence creating an unreasonable risk
find the defendant guilty
here are those charges for you guilty of
second-degree murder
guilty of second-degree manslaughter and
guilty of third
degree murder 12 members plus
two alternates heard the case judge
cahill dismisses the two alternates both
female before
heading into the deliberations seven
women and
five men make up the jury six identify
as white
four as black and two as mixed race
their ages range
from in their 20s to in their
60s brian i want to come out to you
first your immediate reaction
to this verdict
as i was sitting there listening in my
in my earphones as to when the verdict
was coming up
i then got up and started walking around
outside of the hennepin county
government center
where people were congregating it
started with 50 people then 100 people
then 150 and it kept growing
and growing and as judge cahill came out
and started to read the verdict there
was
a kind of sense of calm as he went
through the numbers of the charges and
finally got to that guilty for the top
charge there was a cheer
then a second chair as to the second
guilty and a third chair as to the
guilty on the third count
and it seemed that just everyone just
breathed a sigh of of
relaxing a little bit uh because the
anxiety of waiting to see what would
happen
uh was really pent up and i think my
reaction would be
is that derek chovin murdered george
floyd it's no longer a killing it's no
longer alleged that's no longer accused
uh he murdered george floyd and i think
people
finally see that uh some justice was
found here
all right brian and here in new york
when the verdict was read you
hear from inside the studios we heard
horns honking and cheering outside
here around harold square too terry you
know the jury deliberated for ten
and a half hours do you find that that
was relatively fast
for this sort of case i did think it was
fast because it's a complicated case you
have the three different charges
and the judge gave the elements on each
of those charges
and you have to think that the jury has
been listening to
this evidence for a month now so i think
that they
really cut to the chase they looked at
the two main issues the fact that this
was unreasonable force
the fact that the knee did cause his
death and
exficiation so it came back quickly
there was cheering here in harlem as
well
and i think that there is an overall
universal sigh of relief
all right terry brian thank you
minnesota attorney general keith ellison
spoke after the verdict calling it just
here we are in 2021 still addressing the
same problem
since dr clark testified we have seen
rodney king admiral wema oscar grant
eric garner michael brown freddie gray
sandra bland
philando castile laquan mcdonald stefan
clark
atiana jefferson anton black brianna
taylor
and now dante wright and adam toledo
this has to end we need
true justice that's not one case
that is a social transformation
says that nobody's beneath the law and
no one is above it
this verdict reminds us that we must
make
enduring systemic societal change
and of course prosecutors got the final
word in closing arguments
jerry blackwell ending on this note
for the jury
but i wanted to save to the end what i
thought
was the biggest
shading of the truth or what i call
story
and you'll disregard the phrase shading
the truth
well here's what i thought that was the
largest departure from
here the evidence i'll show it to you
you were told
for example that mr floyd
died that mr floyd died because his
heart was
too big you heard that testimony
and now having seen all the evidence
haven't heard all the evidence
you know the truth and the truth of the
matter is
that the reason george floyd is dead is
because mr sheldon's heart was too small
jerry blackwell covered multiple points
there terry during that rebuttal um
curious which points stood out to you
well i thought that he was very eloquent
when he said
about the heart he also had phrases like
reasonable is
as reasonable does he said that chovin
did not let up he did not get up but the
two points that he really made that he
had to make in that rebuttal
were as to the cause of death and as to
unreasonable fourth nelson
said that the state had to prove that
none of the other factors played a role
jerry blackwell clarified that the state
only has to show
that the defendant's actions were a
substantial factor
and then he also showed that for
reasonable force
nelson said that the state had to prove
that chovin intended
to act unlawfully jerry blackwell made
it very clear that they
only had to prove that he intended to do
what he did so he made some important
rebuttal points
some minor points as well but overall i
thought he did an excellent job
all right terry and and brian what do
you think was the best piece of evidence
that the jury saw during the trial
i think was the video i think that the
prosecution
lined up their arguments lined up the
elements of the crime way better than
eric nelson did i think when the jury
went back and saw where the elements
were saw what the instructions were
they were closer to what the prosecution
was arguing and closer to what they saw
with their very own eyes
on that video i think at the end of the
day this case would not have been
what it was but for donald williams and
those who
recorded what was seen yeah body cam
video is great
but the video the point of view from the
bystanders
who didn't choose to be witnesses but
were selected by happenstance
and what we saw in that video i think
the world saw the jury saw and that's
why we got the conviction
that we heard moments ago absolutely i
think a lot of people would agree with
you there brian
still ahead on law and crime daily
rodney
floyd speaking out in the name of his
brother george floyd
and first our exclusive interview with
the man seen with george floyd on the
day he died
what maurice hall had to say about the
verdict
coming up next
[Music]
the man who was in the car with george
floyd on the day he died pleaded the
fifth
during derrick shobin's trial law and
crime's internet levy
spoke with him just minutes after the
verdict was read the first time he spoke
to anyone
after the verdict actually and jeanette
tell us what he told you
yeah angelica maurice hall was really
supposed to be a key witness for the
defense
in this case since he was in the suv
with george floyd the night that he died
and when police approached
but he ended up invoking his fifth
amendment right against
self-incrimination
and not testifying he actually feared he
could be charged with third degree
murder
for possibly providing drugs to floyd
that night he showed up at the
courthouse
for the reading of the verdict and we
spoke with him
i wanted to make sure that if it was a
guilty trial that i want to promote
positive protests and not burn the city
down if we could that was my main motion
of really being out here today you were
there when this happened that night what
was kind of going through your head when
you were standing there with shawanda
hill and
officer chang and this was all going on
across the street
allegedly i um i had no thoughts at the
time i was
numb you know i couldn't i was being
detained
like the world saw i couldn't i couldn't
really have any emotions
at that time
and maurice hall had watched some of the
trial
actually he was incarcerated for most of
the trial but then posted bail he had
some other cases going on
some criminal cases and i asked him what
he thought about how that prosecution
case
unfolded prosecution done a great job
and it was the right thing to do we all
saw it we all witnessed it
tell me about george floyd how long did
you know him i've been knowing floyd
like 20 21 years
floyd was life full of life you know it
didn't we didn't you didn't have to have
much to
be in his presence and still have fun
you know
he's a sense of humor great sense of
humor god he's a giver
you know most people adders subtractors
and dividers floyd was a ad of
definitely
he he added to your life whether it was
physical presence and he can help or
just his security or his words of
encouragement wisdom you know like
the brother just an all-around team
player
athlete
and i asked hall um after he made
mention of
he said he said i will be at the other
trial for the other three officers
in august and i asked him well what do
you mean you're going to be there are
you going to be testifying are you
getting immunity and
he kind of clammed up when i asked him
that question and referred me to his
attorney so it'll be interesting to see
how that unfolds in the upcoming trial
for the other three officers later in
august
angelica absolutely internet and you
know
he seemed pretty comfortable talking to
you and it was really a casual
conversation he had with you right there
in front of
a lot of people who are out there for
this trial i mean
what was your reaction to him even
speaking to you he even said he might
want to write a book about all this
yeah he did say that and um it was
actually pretty interesting because i
just kind of looked over i was walking
around after the verdicts were read and
i was walking around and i
literally looked and i was thought to
myself i think that's maurice hall
and i went up and i said are you maurice
hall and he said yes i am
and i said well can i talk to you and he
came over to the camera
i had talked to him before we went on
camera his lawyer and his pr
representative wouldn't let him answer
my questions about what happened that
night what was going on in the car they
were like no no no you can't talk to
talk about that but he was willing to
talk about other things so he kind of
knows the score
all right internet thank you great
reporting there
um terry you know the jury came to this
verdict without asking a single question
during this
and this as we know is a confusing
process
now they didn't ask any questions but
they did come to this verdict and again
about 10 uh and a half hours do you
think
that this shows that they were focused
uh what do you think
they were definitely focused you know
they had a lot of evidence that they had
to look over this trial
really began with the jury selections
back on march 9th
and they've been listening to evidence
for weeks now and
multiple witnesses 45 different
witnesses so i think they really cut to
the chase
they understood what the two main issues
were and they came to a great conclusion
here
that really satisfied the world i
believe
absolutely all right terry and jeanette
thank you both coming up next on lawn
crime daily
kristin smart's accused killer is behind
bars after
26 years his plea in court
and rodney floyd's message for
everyone in the memory of his brother
george floyd that's all straight ahead
[Music]
the state of emergency was declared in
the twin cities in anticipation of the
verdict in the derrick chauvin trial
emotions running extremely high there
all day as the nation
waited for this verdict we know that
hundreds of students walked out of
class this week to protest racial
injustice city schools
closed buildings and put distance
learning in place all
out of safety precautions and on top of
that
thousands of national guard soldiers are
guarding grocery stores post offices
laundromats and other landmarks
meanwhile
civil rights leaders like al sharpton
are in town holding press conferences
standing shoulder to shoulder with
floyd's family members
praying another black man won't die at
the hands of police
so many people stepped up in this city
standing up for joy standing up for
what's right what they believe in
because they want to make sure
their family member is not another
hashtag
flight was killed on may 25th
of last year i came a week later to
minneapolis and did the eulogy at his
funeral
it's not even a year later and this
thursday
i'll be doing the eulogy for dante
ranked in minneapolis
this is why this trial is so important
and brian you know you've been there
throughout the whole trial
what's the feeling on the ground there
now post-verdict we know that the
attorney general is asking for illegal
and of course peaceful celebrations how
is it there now
yeah i'm not sure if you can hear but
it's just a lot of honking as
people drive by you can it's a it's
almost celebratory people
are honking they're cheering uh the
protest that was out
outside after the conviction of derek
shovin
was a one of celebration but also one of
this isn't the end this is the beginning
people are starting to take notice
of these types of incidents involving
police violence
and they want to move forward with more
justice all right brian
thank you for your reporting there
coming out of minneapolis
so important that you have been there
throughout the trial when we come back
we will show you how prosecutors are
trying to get a higher sentence
for derrick shovin the judge to decide
the sentence
not the jury that is what he is asking
that's coming up
[Music]
and welcome back a new report says the
capitol police officer who died
following the january
6th riot died of natural causes officer
brian sicknick was involved
in a confrontation with rioters at
the capitol building the washington d.c
chief medical examiner now says the 42
year old died
as a result of multiple strokes at the
base
of his brain stem this is according to
the washington post
the autopsy also shows there was no
evidence of external or internal
injuries to the officer
capitol police released a statement
saying quote
this does not change the fact that he
died
in the line of duty sickness collapsed
in his office and died a few hours
after the protests and the father
and son accused in the disappearance and
alleged
cover-up of a california college student
in 1996
are pleading not guilty cal poly state
university student kristin
smart seemingly vanished 24 years ago
after leaving a party her ex-classmate
paul flores is now charged with
murdering her his father
reuben flores is charged as an accessory
for allegedly helping to hide
her body smart's body is yet to be
recovered but investigators say
they're hopeful they will find it an
attorney for rubin flores told the judge
the most
damning evidence was disturbed soil
police found in his client's backyard
saying that he could provide an innocent
explanation for it
ruben flores is due back in court for a
motion to reduce his bond
on wednesday and back now to the derek
chovin courtroom
the defendant waived his right to a jury
deciding whether he should receive
a higher aggravated sentence
i have specifically advised you
that you have a right to have a jury
decide
whether or not the state has proven
those grounds for an
aggravated sentence beyond a reasonable
doubt
you have a right to have a jury decide
if you violate it
right and i've advised you that the
state has to prove those grounds beyond
a reasonable doubt
right and um
we can waive that right and allow if
you're convicted we can waive your right
to a trial and allow the judge to make
those determinations i've
advised you about that right
now do you want a jury to make a
decision
about the proof required
for the aggravated factors if there's a
conviction or are you willing to waive
your right to a trial on those matters
and allow judge cahill to make those
decisions
i'm willing to waive it and have judge
cagle to sign on those issues
all right terry this is the second time
the judge has personally spoken to derek
chauvin
why do you think it was important for
the judge to talk to him
about waving his blakely rights well you
saw there angelica that not only
did nelson talk to his client but it is
important for
the judge to speak to the client because
he has to make sure
that the client understands that he's
waiving his rights the first time was
when he
waived his right to take the stand and
this time he waived his right to have
the jury decide the aggravating factors
and to let the judge decide that so it's
important that he understands
not only from his own attorney but the
judge wants to make sure
that he clearly understands those rights
all right terry thank you brian what do
you expect the defense might do
now that we have the verdict what's
their next move
maybe appeals what do you think
the next move is sentencing what derek
chauvin
with his attorney eric nelson has got to
do is try to drive that
sentencing number as low as possible
yes appeals are going to be coming but
first the first step here is
what's the number we know the top count
comes with 40 years in jail but those
four
aggravating factors that were raised by
the prosecution
uh the fact that a crime occurred in
front of miners the fact that he was
particularly vulnerable
the fact that this was cruel and the
fact that three or more people
participated in a crime
are all factors that eric nelson has to
push back on
and try to find some reasonable doubt
things can be difficult to try to get a
lower sentence
all right brian thank you for that
reporting thank you all for joining us
here on law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you